I asked my wife if I could borrow her
headphones and I realized she's a
monster
what is stakes don't sue me raise her
it's cool it's cool I got this that's
better
how's it going everyone we're playing
lots of us too it's out it's 8:00 in the
morning not many games send me up this
early that would suck there's just that
Noah is his title screen I know last of
us yeah that's right I played the first
last of us was it seven years ago I
can't remember how long but it was a
while ago I literally had the same meme
where I'm like should I order the game
online I was like [ __ ]
[Music]
there's no game stores to open right now
is either wise that probably would have
gone to the game so it's funny huh seven
years later I still have a crappy
internet I was like god dammit it's
gonna take me forever to play this but
somehow I managed to fix my internet so
it's working
no one cares you care about the life of
us great me too
I loved the first game it was one of the
biggest playthroughs I've ever done on
this channel I've been getting messages
for weeks literally asking me yes I'm
gonna play it it's happening and Here I
am delivering that's right probably the
most anticipated game in a very long
time when I played this game last of us
for the first time it was a special time
for me because it was when I was just
about to become the biggest channel on
YouTube because I I don't get excited
for games very often and I've been
extremely excited for this one I'd
literally be counting the youtubes and I
was neck or neck with this other channel
and I was a bit worried about it I
thought I only get one chance in this in
my life I need to deliver and then this
game came out and delivered for me cuz
it was massive for the channel so thanks
for that respect that's of course why
we're gonna play The Last of Us
two lights go yeah oh I'm a pro gamer
we'll play survivor let's go yeah
inverted what am i a psychopath come on
did I do it alright here we go let's go
new playthrough yeah let's get high yeah
it's only gonna be epic yeah
I swear playing naughty guy dog games is
worth it just for the graphics they
always look amazing
what does it mean hey remember the
ending of lots of us it's Joel I'm
supposed to take her to the fireflies
and walk away
you go halfway across the country with
someone
damn that's some reminescent she needed
her immunity to mean something oh maybe
I was starting to buy an old cured
business ah maybe I just wanted to do
right by her
yes yeah and then we made it
you found a fire fire thanks for
reminding us of what the story ended
they were actually gonna make a cure can
we get one please can I have one of
those
you know a killer what are you doing I
won't let you take her there's a few
days think of all the lives we'll safe
Joline thinking that way Jesus Christ
Joe what do you do now then saved her
Jesus Christ I forgot it's a big shoot
up in the end ah they'll find someone
else come on
come on that gets artists clean already
Joe yeah that's
that's a lot
or really know she knows stress to me
she knows yeah I totally just ran some
tests I told her her immunity mean
nothing that's why you wake up in the
car after a surgery you do that all the
time right
hell no
[Music]
didn't say otherwise
well this is gonna be a big deal later
we should head back
all right do I get to play question mark
I believe yes
hey the horses are back nice I get to
ride them they do that meme where
oh a my actually playing the game wow
dude that looks gorgeous uh well done
look at that Wow told you sorry I got
distracted by the scenery and I didn't
see where he went there we go
[Music]
amazing
damn kind of wish this is out on
PlayStation 5 cuz they always push it
you know it still looks good this super
thick this is what next-gen would feel
like
damn all that one a gallop yeah whoa
[Music]
let's go make a jump oh we don't need to
nevermind do a little circle for no
reason just testing out all right I can
do circles no big deal
we do a little jump
oh hell no I ain't doing that all right
okay I probably we're doing this goddamn
horses a crazy
no more gasps huh whoa
[Music]
do I have a gun I don't want this guitar
come on
it's crazy how how much time they're
probably spent building that little area
and you just ride through it without
thinking coolest if we're going to camp
huh
stop
should we not stop alright alright
what is this gate build out of wood
chin are there are magic card entries as
cool
alright alright
let's go howdy
Wow whoa
what set a coincidence a look that way
you go on you sure
about what we were talking about earlier
I can't say I have done different
I'll take to the grave I have to a good
thing you just told them
I'll see you later but I sacrifice Edgar
for the cure of mankind
absolutely Edgar just so you know you're
irreplaceable
[Music]
I'm kidding I'm joking where's that late
Oh she's drawing the bunny that she
murdered huh is that what you're doing
Ellie you feeling bad now I remember
early hell is she listening to
Jesus its gave me a heart attack I tried
knocking but hey hey what's up Joel why
is this I walk guard just check it in
folks were talking about how impressed
they are with you and how well you're
helping out it's good yeah that's better
Tommy that was the saint riding the
other day and yeah they told me a joke
I thought about you it's him oh shoot I
forgot it that's about clock Hadees
y'all it's uh it's pretty late and I
gotta get up in a few hours
I'm gonna get out of your hair just I
want to show you something just give me
one second
what's this it's a gift
yeah no strings though some folks call
this thing I strung it or funny you only
yourself okay okay place caramelldansen
come on promise me that you won't laugh
oh I want dressed in you oh my god am I
playing a gal piss I'll pick a G I was a
minor I don't know the difference swine
oh I am actually this way
[Music]
hey little girl we kill the sound me I
like to you girl about killing the
zombies sorry about that by the way
[Music]
oh I'm supposed to pick the court my bad
it doesn't [ __ ] work
I need it on a controller oh my god I'm
stupid I'm supposed to play it after
that way they wanted sorry I'm sorry my
brain entirely if I ever were to lose
you I for my versa surely lose person
[Music]
trying sometimes you'll succeed to make
his faith early Oh stolen missing parts
I have no need for
[Music]
and I believe I can see here two days
days are you with me
[Music]
Joel's gotta get so many girls come on
come on Joel
very nice well that didn't suck I don't
take what I can get she's yours oh no no
I don't know the first thing about that
I teach you how to play did you do that
in the first came out and remember I'm
curious just what do you say tomorrow
night first lesson yeah
okay
because a watch got shot or no enough
shot in that cracked-up it didn't do you
remember the joke what is the downside
to eating a clock it's time-consuming
that's so dumb yeah hey yes it is
you should've entered it with the guitar
oh come on
damn it's so strange looking at this
game cuz it obviously looks so good but
it's a bit uncanny valley to when you
see their expressions being so well made
that it's that whoa wait that's very
light okay
oh no oh oh we know what happened no no
oh they grew up no excuse me what the
hell is this hey the hell are you
overslept just give me a minute and I'll
get dressed I heard you had quite a
night after I left I the hell does that
mean she kissed me it was just Dina
being Dina shouldn't mean anything by it
I was talking about your fight with Seth
wait you kiss Adina oh I thought open up
one week and you make a move on my girl
she's probably just trying to make you
jealous I didn't I would never I'm
messing with you man
I don't care get dressed
you're the worst it's kind of [ __ ] up
be today yeah smells fine Ellie you're
nasty
now what the hell are it's
jacksepticeye's band whoa
savage starlight I love it
pioneered of science in astronomy
she likes Neil deGrasse Tyson next at
bay how the [ __ ] did she live in this
house has not I insulator whatever is
called in English in the snowy mountain
come on gotta be freezing how'd I get it
all up shut up just about to get up
I was we're gonna get bunnies yes I just
want to kind of look around it's so
impressive what they built here
I know I mean Ellie's character always
it looks good but just looking at the
background itself it feels so real
amazing heads up you're the talk of the
town this morning what you had a fight
in your kiss see if I got this right
you kissed Deena she kissed me which
triggered set to call you a not-so-nice
word yep
then Joel decadent Marla push and then
you got mad at Joel that part confused
me it was a strange night man
sounds exciting sorry I missed alright
so that's how they get their veggies Wow
how many people live in this town do you
reckon I got some cucumbers yes Bob
Gaines yes
and Merc I'd be pretty yeah come on
Maria wants a word with you
where is she diner I love how they put
up a fairy lights no clue just see it
you never saw me
apakah let's put up some [ __ ] fairies
your [ __ ] loyalty
don't [ __ ] squares me Milo you do
your thing
Oh do I get to press why thank you look
at that guy's
I can play video games oh yeah hey so ok
you and me yeah of course
Deena and I are done I know it's just I
want you to think Elly cool
damn look nice I don't believe him Hey
apocalypse ain't so bad huh whoa there's
so much animated like a whole set
oh hey little doggy oh it's that girl
Hey time yeah get a good scratch you
ain't getting [ __ ] again you ain't
getting no scratches look at my kids the
hell are they doing good on the air
lights cringe God self a butcher
I got this dude he's like my eyes my
hand is frozen shut
he's gonna play cool oh pardon me this
is fun look hey Jessie
oh hi up big trades only no Bitcoin come
on that's the future
we got the winter dance wonder what's
gonna happen at the wide-open door what
thank you wanna grab some breakfast I
was really thinking what they eat for
breakfast in the back wow this is so
cozy
excuse me Ellie
there you are come here that's not
something you want to say to you I don't
want to hear what that big it has to say
do it for me please
fine Seth yes apologize hey
look last night I was I was drinking too
much
sure I'm trying to say I'm sorry
caught off a piece of my ass Maria tells
me that you and Dean are headed out yeah
I made you some sandwiches okay I'm
waiting for the backhanded compliment
Thank You Seth yeah doctor yep I
appreciate that
what you got there bigoted sandwiches
mm-hmm
smells good they're yours you sure it's
fine can you walk you out don't skip out
on breakfast and Lee come on please
close the door all right that's got to
be freezing please close okay thank God
when you go out I want you to trade off
with Tommy and Joel those boys have been
out for far too long
where do I meet them you go up to the
northwest look out they're scheduled to
arrive later today watch yourself
there's too many sightings of infected
recently of course squirrel I was gonna
check out the creek trails
I'll need someone else to cover it Ellie
you know the creek trails really Dina's
done it a bunch I'll have the two of
them take at cinema let's go I said
take care now I guess oh my god that's
so cute
my baby's doomed first aid fund poor
Ellie and I talk to you for sec yeah no
look I don't know what's going on with
you and Joel Maria guy really cares
about you and I'm sure he didn't mean to
fine yeah yeah okay okay sorry to pry be
safe thanks yo Dina assignments give me
a minute we could change the mob ain't
trash can I talk to you hey guys for how
long
everyone knows he can throw the last
fall if you have it in your hand what
the hell self restraint on that man god
damn um I just want to say sorry for
running off last night
oh that's it's okay I totally get it I I
just I felt bad why
because I started the whole thing and I
just I shouldn't have kissed you in
front of all of those people and when
you were drunk that's fine well still I
just I don't want you to think I'm not
reading into it or anything you know
what I love about you how you let me
finish my sentences all right well we
should probably get going yeah yeah
there you go told you hey you want to
[ __ ] him up yeah I do definitely didn't
I hear that right
oh we get to shoot there well yeah
you're dead you day hey is that we're
doing sweetie would chase you down
[ __ ] would chase you down I am
humble where's that big another one yeah
yeah you can't run from this reason man
with the ball Thanks yeah you can't run
you're terrible
you're better days where you going son
yeah can I not crowd you like for real
oh sorry never word for this in Sweden
but I can't say all right we actually
have some work to do I guess I asked for
that huh yep so the character Deena I
saw on YouTube she's just I don't know
wants us to do the creek trail Ritchie I
don't think she's the one doing the
movement they just took her together
yeah it is nice you're gonna like this
route right they just took her face and
scanned it girls that's gotta be so
weird just have your game I can't speak
dave's part of a game like that thank
you
so someone else is doing the mocap is
what I'm saying hey speaking of mocap
moe moe moe
all right damn Oh Sarah me the hell oh
hell yeah oh I thought we're gonna melt
cows Danni disappointing
alright time to write out that's a good
girl
look who's here Thanks come on
and shimmer
look who decided to join us yeah yeah
one for you and one for you
open it up settle down chill all right
you all know the drill
run your routes lock your logbooks clear
any infected you see you run into
anything you can't handle you come back
be smart about
all right
get going we're gonna shoot some zambese
hell yeah
[Music]
whoa looks so cool is that another city
am I crazy
[Music]
so this is the new character in the this
series I don't remember her name
sleeping during the day and [ __ ] what
the hell
Hey
goddamn she's strong pain [ __ ] out
kind of protein are they feeding in was
he talking you're doing here
teeth crying anything where have you
been
grab your gear I want to show you
something why trust me
it's got to be a reason they should be
made earlier myself up this way some
purpose why I'm playing as har it's cold
okay
you sure you don't want to do this one
the sun's out and it's warmer no I can't
wait and you don't want to just tell me
you need to see it I was a lot making
tracks in the snow in games and see how
realistic it is and it definitely passes
look at that goddamn
am I the only one bothered by all the
light gear that they're wearing oh I
know which X - yeah of course I know
what do you think
what are you doing wandering around out
here by yourself
been Restless you to feel like the
farther south we go the prettier it's
gotten you want to keep going just drive
all the way to Mexico probably nicer
than that it I could see Manny's
hometown I can see everyone up to his
stories and no probably not
I already figured that out thank you
that's what I was trying to do before
you did all this in the dark yes come on
impossible I can't do that I got did
I just do a little charge before I jump
up that's why I did that you keep going
like this we're gonna be tired for
today's trip it's not that far he is Mel
okay
she seemed out of it these past few days
she'll be fine
you stop being weird you're freaking me
out and my stupid weird sorry
well what a fall look at that it's gotta
be takes so many people to work on this
can you say something you say something
yeah let's jump that seems worth it
that ain't not worth a oh good jump are
you serious are you serious
unbothered breaking up with milk what no
you wish I've had my fill
thank you oh I got a spring John to make
it again all be as graceful as you
clearly what is that you'll be fine
it's too high one whoa okay take it easy
eyes on me
Abby stop looking down
oh yeah tell me what to do we have to go
back this way can I jump off I'm
legitimately curious no God you can go
so close
Abby stop flirting now he can't walk up
that'd be funny though I mean not funny
but he's so funny you know I mean
okay that look back what the hell hey
last of us what happened everything else
is perfect stop making me squeeze
through a B can't do wait
guess it makes sense to introduce a new
character is this kind of like I made it
yeah
have you told anyone else wanted you to
see first
I saw an armed patrol go from town to an
outpost over there a few more outposts
in between
they have electricity guns it's a lot of
people
we can figure it out whatever you're
playing
don't ruin a assuming he's in there how
do we get to it nila patrols and get
confirmation and then I don't know maybe
find a way to wear him out yeah okay
sure they'll be happy to offer that
information well then we make them you
hear yourself
okay what do you want to do
what is going on with you he's not in it
anymore else pregnant
oh okay
it's not just that though should I say
congrats and everyone else sees this
they're gonna want to turn back we can
convince great
[ __ ] knew I couldn't count on you
happy I will you want but not at any
cost
damn hey Josh
see you back at the lodge
a lot of questions who is now what is
their relationship who are they looking
for where did they come from
where did they go where did they become
from [ __ ] one hambo
does she have a gun seems like a
rational reasonable mind that we're
dealing with here like to see what this
is going I'll just jump off here
I've done this in Sweden many times no
problem guys I got this got a run here I
swear I ran what the hell all right we
can do the other way around
it's classic this is the achievement you
own luck to do it twice yeah I did that
game I did that that's why I did it I'm
a pro gamer I make no mistakes
we're gonna walk all the way there short
hike that looks like a really long honey
slide under yeah
I'll prone got it thrown all the way ooh
[Music]
that's what she said you heard her say
oh hell no I forget to kill the zombies
not alive oh he is alive oh god I got a
problem with my controller
hopefully I won't have to change we'll
see
that's a lot of dead
this is like the walk-in then where the
cold keeps us azam bees away
jump-scare and one two three four damn
jeez damn that looks creepy yeah she
says that's messed up dead i keeping my
going
[Music]
[ __ ] huge zombies now damn pretty
cool combo it's reaching for my gun man
[Music]
yeah all right they're dead it's my l2
on the controller that's busted as long
as I don't have to do that we should be
okay it's not like you ain't me that
normally or something cool we got some
gameplay finally and I suck at it
a lot of weapons you could use here
Pepe I'll call her Debbie now and
remember her name was it
how do I get out of here same way you
came in dude that's a duck
amazing oh I don't know one take that
huh just let a fire in the snow will
melt and we can get out all right well I
guess we climbed something do anything
to climb you can you can stop touching
it thank you oh there was a hole in the
ground
jump-scare and once
okay I get to shoot now I can't I got a
check control aside okay now we shoot
I'm sorry for that guys yeah think I got
him in the head you're dead how does
that feel like I was turning it to feel
like for you not that big you're dead I
got four shots a let's make him captain
now what is the reason she wants to go
there so badly huh all right she's
getting closer
nope not at all she better not be gone
for Joel because I'm killing y'all not
gonna happen
let's squeeze through oh yeah
it's alright you just shoot him in the
face I want to listen
my razor headphones so good what kind of
books
books books in world Matt and his books
books and world again no one would have
two copies of books in world hey what's
wrong with you why you got two copies of
books of world a put her ass
it's a silencer or you could do that
yeah that's also silent yes you got
bullets something yet again respect all
right
Debbie's got to do what they bees gotta
do her name is Debbie right yeah is that
anymore
alright let's be stuffy from how I
forgot you keys so that's not how you
it's that what she said cuz that's what
she should have said never mind [ __ ]
something all right
wonder whether I guess the fungus
doesn't grow as much in the coal is that
but they're still zombies is that the
idea you climb over this should we
listen if there's something there's
something on the other side yet
I heard a car guys
let's go for ourself calc
hey John
more like Johnny was gone Johnny gone
week Johnny Johnny Oh Johnny boy living
on the west side
sleeping they don't see me I stood the
listen thing so we can get an idea
and with sneaky andrás town and rich man
we're on Young
your double bed is your zombie and then
you're dying again how's that feel by
twice you're Katie sucks bro and my KD
Debbie KD so large part of this [ __ ] go
[ __ ]
maybe she's gonna turn again
turn around and our children
come on
all right where are you going
everyone knows if even if I'm in cover
they can't see me
impossible feel like a deaf [ __ ] doing
you a favor
sleep damn that face oh god oh god no
sorry sorry sorry sorry wait for him to
go we're and then we took this [ __ ] 25
walk yeah you come with me we on the
floor now floor gang 20% muscle creates
more like 200% but whatever
really should I hold two prong I'll try
that next time
okay so what do I do here again game you
remind me
I should not be oh [ __ ] nevermind okay
so there's many different routes gotcha
gotcha yeah climb over these oh yeah
climb as I said yeah
more strikes
where's the patrol barely here
I would not I heard that unless I had
this sometimes
horse tracks Marcin my little homeless
dude that hoarsely gotta be freezing
oh is it Ellis tracks come on this way
really thank you
we get to ride at Le horses now yeah
this is better I prefer this you miss
being with him Jessie no so if I
remember correct Maximus DLC that was
revealed that Ellie was gay we'll always
be family but I'm surprised so many
people are shocked by the trailer it's
real already knew I never talked about
this stuff I don't know it was Cupid
she'll you never really talked but it
wasn't this girl was it no it wasn't
because there isn't much to talk about
yeah girlfriend just I got the
impression that you didn't really like
her the other I'm crazy I go this way
you never know Oh talented artist I've
grown to like that tattoo of yours
that's so big of you and I think she
wasn't right for you
Ellie's got a tattoo ain't that your
singing shut up okay
whoa forget the job
yeah spit a [ __ ] all right simmer down
shamrock
hey you want to see something
spectacular you're gonna put in your
face aren't you is that supposed to walk
behind horse says I don't trust that
come on stupid Jurgen one uragan too
good to see you okay gonna end the first
part there god damn so beautiful we have
a lot in front of us if you want to be
so kind sure your support on this video
it always helps and I really appreciate
it subscribe rate and all that epicness
see you guys in the next part is gonna
be good
prophase